The joe rogan experience.
Do you watch those movies and shake your head?
I like him.
I just knew I liked science fiction,
you know?
Right.
You know,
so yeah,
I didn't sit there.
I grew up with star wars.
That was my,
when I was nine years old or some finances.
Yeah.
I'm not having this.
I did,
I did a,
an argument with Neil,
the grass tight,
not an argument,
but a debate with him about lightsabers ones cause I claimed that they're
physically the in principle there possible.
Um,
and he was trying to say that they aren't,
but they are what did have to loop back around cause the light's not continuing
to like the fact that it goes to a certain distance and pauses.
We don't have a mirror or something,
I guess.
Yeah.
Something that's true to be the end of it.
Right.
That's true.
So it wouldn't,
it'd be a different kind of light.
So the only point was making is that photons,
particles of light can bounce off each other.
So we see that in really high energy experiments in particle accelerators.
We can collide photons together.
So my point was a bit of a pedantic physicist one but he's,
cause he,
it is true that light can bounce off.
It can hit light but very,
very high energy.
But when they press that button to a certain distance,
I wasn't,
that's engineering.
I agree with you.
The distance thing,
I agree mass to it.
Right.
So as you're swinging it around,
you wouldn't have the leverage of a long thing.
So why not make it really long?
Cause it wouldn't be difficult to swing around.
Like you could stab someone with a lightsaber a mile away.
That's true.
Well I shoot a laser in it.
Yes.
Like why,
why make it so short?
You have to swing,
you got to be close to hitting a person with it.
That's a silly,
silly design.
You are picking holes correctly in the engineering.
Part of my,
the only point I was making is that physics is,
that we shutting is quite interesting is it light can bounce off light.
So,
but it would have to do,
it would have to be something that causes it to stop at the very end.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Which would be,
you're right,
you'd have a merit,
but he wouldn't look cool with it if there was a no kind of thing within,
which drives me crazy about star wars is not the light sabers.
It's the lasers when they're shooting the guns.
So I'm like,
why can I see that when I can't see bullets?
This is,
we're supposed to be way faster than a bullet.
Yeah.
Like easy to see this because it's like George,
you could duck,
you can get out of the way.
Those things,
they really slow.
I'm so angry.
I feel like this is so dumb.
I could go warp speed in this Millennium Falcon and travel the speed of light,
but for whatever reason,
these lasers are so slowly you could duck out of the way of them.
That's so dumb.
And he's not only star wars is,
it's everything.
Uh,
the epigenome is quite difficult.
Different.
The epigenome is that the structure of how the DNA is looped around.
If you look at the chromosome,
you're not seeing the gene Amil.
It really basically saying epigenome and what w what I think is causing aging is
not that you're losing the DNA structure,
you're not having mutations.
You're actually changing the epigenome,
which is the,
the reader of the genes.
To put another way,
a compact disc,
okay.
Uh,
for the young audience,
uh,
come back.
Discs are little things we used to put music on.
But anyway,
these are,
these are digital information of course.
And the reason we switched to digital in the first place is that it's very
copyable and it doesn't wear out.
Whereas a,
a cassette tape,
you know,
people our age know that if you try to copy that a thousand times,
there's not much left at the end.
So that the compact disc inflammation is the genome.
The epigenome is the reader of the CD,
that little laser that goes around.
And what I think is causing aging is not the loss of the digital information,
but it's the reader at the analog pot.
And that's like a cassette tape that eventually runs out.
So what we,
what's going on really is that your cells are losing the ability to read the
right genes the way they did when you were 20.
And that's basically noise,
informational noise that gathers over time.
Um,
and so what we end up with when we're 80 is a compact disc or DVD that
scratched.
So the reader cannot read the right genes,
the right time,
and the cells become dysfunctional.
Now what we're working on is how do you Polish that CD or that DVD to get that
information back again?
And if you could do that,
I think that's really the best way to reset your age.
And I,
we haven't published it yet,
but,
uh,
we're working on ways to actually reset that genome,
actually get back the information that we once had when we were 20.
So what is happening to the epigenome when you're going through those scanners?
Well,
so what we found is the biggest disruptor of the epigenome is,
uh,
a broken chromosome and DNA break.
And I don't know about scanners,
that's just an abundance of caution.
But an x ray will damage your DNA,
no question.
Um,
even going out in the sun,
we'll do a bit of that.
And we think that the cells reaction to that break having to unwrap the DNA from
its Chromatin,
we call it,
and uh,
and then rewrap it is what eventually disrupts the ability to read the right
gene at the right place.
So Dna damage is essentially a s a little scratch on,
on the DVD.
And that accumulates over time.
A lot of people are not willing to learn how to do that because they want the
fast track out,
take a drug and pass out.
That is the thing,
right?
They just want a pill.
Yeah.
It's very unfortunate that those things exist in that,
that that sort of thinking is,
you know,
it's reinforced.
Yeah.
It's encouraged.
In fact,
you know,
all these ads and all these doctors and different people,
well if you have a hard time sleeping,
I'll just write your prescription.
And then next thing you know,
and I mean you look at the animal world,
like they self medicate,
they'll use clay for parasites and you know,
dogs leak grass for stomach issues.
And you know that I guess birds now are putting like nicotine and cigarettes and
their nests cause there's some of benefit to that and you see animals
self-medicating,
you see our ancestors using everything from you know,
cannabis to Ceylon cinnamon to you know,
all sorts of different derivatives for thousands of years.
So it's not like supplementation or self medication or the or the whole creation
of pharmaceuticals is something that's unnatural or not acceptable human
activity.
But once you start to use it as a crutch,
I think that's where you run into issues like once,
once you deny the human body's ability to be able to heal itself or to be able
to decrease stress on its own,
you begin to rely on these exogenous chemicals.
I think that's where you start playing with fire.
The idea that you're going to be this balance,
chilled out person and still be a fucking world.
Smasher good luck with that.
I'm the farthest thing from relaxed and chill.
You know,
I try to learn now,
but,
but when you're training and when you look,
there's a mindset that's required to beat the best guys,
and it's not the same mindset that's required to get good to get,
you could get good and be a chilled out,
relaxed person.
Like say you want to be a black belt in Jujitsu,
that's totally possible.
You can be really good.
People can go,
Hey,
look at Mike Mann.
Mike has got great triangle.
Watch them raw.
Wow,
he's really good.
But if Mike wants to be the motherfucker have motherfuckers,
you better be crazy.
You know,
you better be God damn crazy.
You better be like Mike Tyson when he was young.
Yup.
Be those Michael Jordan's you're talking about,
they're always thinking about it.
Roy Jones Jr yes.
All of those guys.
You gotta be a fucking crazy person.
Absolutely.
Roy Jones Jr played a professional basketball game the day of his fight.
Played a guy in a basketball game,
did not have competitive.
Do any.
Just an athlete.
Yeah.
I mean,
I just don't think there's any other way.
I think if you're going to win a race,
you're going to red line the engine because I just don't see how you're going to
beat the best guy.
Everybody is trying their best.
This is the thing.
There's so much going on there.
I mean you could have like a really good coach so you have an advantage.
Technically you could have a really good group of guys you train with,
so you have an advantage in the environment that you're training in and there's
a lot of inspiration.
But if you're not a fucking psychopath,
good luck.
I know my friend Sam Harris was trying to get you guys to ban Donald Trump.
He was saying if the fall,
your terms of service,
I just did a podcast with him actually as well.
It should come out today or tomorrow.
He's uh,
he's a,
he's a fascinating guy.
Sam Harris.
I love him to death.
But what he was trying to do was like saying,
hey,
he's threatening nuclear war.
Like he's saying,
Hey Korea,
my bombs are bigger than your bombs.
Like,
what else does the guy have to do to get your,
to remove them from the platform?
When you guys saw that,
what,
what was your reaction to that?
Was there an internal discussion about actually banning the president of United
States?
Well,
so,
so two things there.
One,
it was a context that presidents of this country have you similar language in
different mediums.
They use it on radio,
use it on television.
It's not just through Twitter.
And even if you were looking at,
you were to look at the presidency of Obama.
It wasn't exactly the same tone in this exact same language,
but there were threats around the same country.
And we have to take that context into consideration.
So the second thing is that we need the most controversial aspect of our rules
and our terms of services.
Probably this clause around public interest in newsworthiness where,
um,
powerful figures are public figures,
might,
uh,
be in violation of our terms of service.
But the tweet itself is of public interest.
Yes,
there should be a conversation around it.
And that is probably the thing that people disagree with the most.
Um,
and where we have a lot of internal debate,
but we also have some pretty hard lines.
If we had a global leader,
including the president of United States,
make a violent threat against a private individual,
we would take action.
We,
we always have to balance that with like,
is this a,
is this something that the public has interest in it?
And I,
I believe generally the answer is yes.
It's not going to be in every case,
but generally the answer is yes,
because we should see how our leaders think and how they act.
Okay.